turning now to pioneering business
and pro sports team owner that Sheila
Johnson she is part owner of the NHL's
Washington Capitals the NBA's Washington
Wizards and has a stake in the
Washington Mystics of the WNBA you go
Sheila Johnson who co-founded bet was
recently named CEO of the Year by
Washington Business Journal and she owns
five-star Resorts around the world she
is a badass CBS Saturday morning calls
that's Michelle Miller spoke with
Johnson about how she became the first
black female billionaire in the personal
challenges she overcame along the way
[Music]
go caps when it comes to the Washington
Capitals
Kayla Johnson's what you call a proud
vocal partner
[Applause]
did you ever see yourself as a
professional sports Mogul no I wouldn't
call myself a mogul still the 2018
Stanley Cup champ scored an ultimate
Trifecta for her I know when things are
going to work and when they're not going
to work I really trust my instinct
making Johnson the first and only black
woman with an ownership stake in three
professional sports teams I have the
wonderful WNBA national champions 2019
Washington Mystics
I have the Wizards which we're still
working on
for a title and then we have the 2018
NHL capitals
and how does that fit in it's my side
gig it's my side gig her Story begins in
Maywood Illinois her mother an
accountant her father one of only 11
black neurosurgeons in the country you
talk about learning resilience we had to
move 13 times because my father could
not practice in white hospitals and
everyone asked me you know moving that
much what was your childhood like I
thought it was an adventure Her First
Act in life was as a concert violinist
but it was in 1980 that Johnson took the
first step in building an empire when
she co-founded bet along with her
ex-husbands
talk about those early days what was
your vision the whole purpose of
starting bet was to give the African
Americans a voice it was the birth of
cable and everything that was being
pumped out there from CNN and
Nickelodeon you name it nobody talked
about the importance of the
African-American voice if I could do it
all over again my voice could be
listened to
I think the network would have looked a
little different more news less
entertainment but by 2001 the network
sold to Viacom and cement cement Johnson
in history as the first black woman
billionaire you don't like that title I
don't like it why money's not everything
it's how you use what you have to make
things like work and make your life work
her life took a turn when she divorced
in 2002 a pivotal moment where she
realized she lost herself in her
marriage you didn't kind of withdraw
into the Shadows
and take on their identity and one of
the biggest lessons I've learned in life
was that shouldn't have happened
I lost sight of who I really was you
emerged after the divorce it took me two
years but I figured out finally who I
was it was like a rebirth shortly after
she remarried and that rebirth became
the jumping off point for her
Hospitality Empire that now includes
everything from a PGA golf course to
Resorts around the world including the
salamander in Middleburg Virginia a
place she now calls home it's buzzing
she had this idea Betsy Davis has lived
in Middleburg her whole life and says
since the opening of the resort in 2005
this area has seen a growth in business
by almost 70 percent
there's a difference in thriving and
surviving and and we will always survive
but this
energy that's helped us to really Thrive
a stone's throw from horse country is
the nation's capital and a cause close
to the longtime equestrian creating a
better life for police horses the living
conditions of these horses was
unbelievable we saw rats in the grain
areas where you know they get their food
you can see the desperation in their
eyes and they had been in those weeds
since 1976 with the purpose that they
were going to get a new home but it
never happened and she did the left here
is where the by helping to raise over 22
million dollars to build these new
Stables people don't realize yeah you've
got the nation's living room here but
this living room has to be protected
using her Empire to give back is at the
core of Johnson's work a far cry from
the little girl whose childhood dream
was to take the classical music scene by
storm my mother always told me to never
say can't she hated that word that you
can't do something and I think
especially for young women
they need to find out who they are first
this is a very important path Johnson
says she's now in her third act and is
the happiest she's ever been I don't
regret anything that has happened to me
personally or anything because I
wouldn't be sitting here talking to you
and everything that happened to me has
made me who I am now
and it's been a big year for Johnson she
acquired the prestigious Mandarin
Oriental Hotel here in Washington and
she might be adding another sports team
or two to her roster both the Washington
Nationals the baseball team and the
commanders the football team could be up
for sale by the end of this year and she
and her Partners they're high up on the
list of potential buyers
Michelle Michelle you captured her
beautifully listen I have such
admiration and for her she is such a
badass and she is such a class act so we
know it seems that divorce certainly was
very difficult for her but she came back
with a vengeance she found new love
she's now a huge huge force in the
business industry you really did her
justice so thank you I mean she's very
she's transparent and and you know you
don't find many uh humble
multi-millionaires out there but she's
one of them oh man she's awesome yeah
well done Michelle